a dismal rainy day at the United Nations
A fitting backdrop to a bleak status
update on the progress of important U.N
pledges they are called sustainable
development goals or sdgs adopted in
2015 17 core promises to improve the
globe and the lives of the people on it
by 2030. the importance clear on the
lawn of the complex now a visual
reminder of how far countries have
fallen short at this the Midway point
one goal ending hunger the U.N says last
year 9.2 percent of the global
population
experienced chronic hunger that
translates into
735 million people on preventing the
worst impacts of climate change
greenhouse gas emissions need to be
halved by 2030. commitments from the 193
countries that signed the Paris climate
Accord are predicted to mean a reduction
of just 0.3 percent
yet today only 15 percent of the targets
are on track
and many are going in reverse the
majority seem to agree on the reasons
the most blame goes to the covet
pandemic
The Fragile progress made has been
undermined by Wars such as the war of
aggression launched by Russia and
Ukraine by pandemics climate change
widespread violations of human rights
many nations promising to do better my
country
will spare no efforts to reduce the
rates of poverty Nationwide including
poverty in families especially those
with many children others explaining why
they haven't met the goals unfortunately
continuous acts of progression Against
The Sovereign territory of Armenia
warmongering and hateful rhetoric of the
highest leadership of Azerbaijan
threatened the security and stability in
our region overall the general message
it's bad in many ways it's not getting
better and that needs to end now
in the end let us remember that the
pathway to build a new world that is
safer more Equitable and free is through
achieving international human solidarity
the UN has laid out the steps that the
world needs to take and the countries
did sign another declaration a promise
to redouble their efforts but given the
geopolitical strife and really
constrained government budgets it's not
yet clear if this high-level meeting
will result in heightened progress
paddickle Hayne Al Jazeera at the United
Nations
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera